ils ont quitté leurs exploitations
respectives leurs champs ou leurs bêtes
pour venir manifester à tour aujourd'hui
de nombreux agriculteurs et une centaine
de tracteurs se sont donné rendez-vous
ce midi dans le centre ville tourangeau
une opération de communication pour
dénoncer l'accumulation des normes
européennes et françaises auxquelles ils
sont soumis
dernier point de crispation en date les
distances à respecter entre les zones
traitées et les points d'eau où les
habitations plus d'explications avec
samuel colin s'il convergent tous les
agriculteurs n'ont pas les mêmes
revendications
pour certains c'est la question des
produits des pesticides interdits
pour d'autres les taxes notamment
américaines sur le vin globalement il y
dénonce un trop plein de règles qui les
rendent moins compétitifs face à la
concurrence internationale nous enlever
des choses mais après derrière on n'a
rien on n'a rien proposé d'autre que les
lois changent toutes les tous les six
mois et il y en a marre y en a marre on
est vraiment aujourd'hui comme en ayant
marqué à la culotte et ça devient
insupportable pour les agriculteurs une
décision qui les fait bondir les zones
non traitées
des bandes de 5 à 100 m à l'abord des
habitations ou des cours d'eau cela
enlèverait de 3 à 5000 hectares de
cultures dans le département sûrement en
exploitation ça me fait perdre deux
hectares et demi ça représente surtout
de l'entretien pour rien un fermage
qu'il faut payer aussi donc c'est de la
surface de perdus ils ne comprennent pas
la qualification des cours d'eau retenue
par la préfecture sur certains fossés ya
pas de problème il ya de l'eau tout le
temps pourquoi pas mais sur certains
fossés où il n'y a pas d'eau
quasiment ebuya de l'eau quasiment
jamais c'est des mesures supplémentaires
qui mon sens ne sont pas nécessairement
d'où ce coup de force et ce débarquement
en centre ville arrivé vers 12h30 place
jean jaurès la circulation automobile et
rapidement bloqué objectifs de l'action
être vu et entendu une délégation doit
rencontrer la préfète
soit on a des mes actions qui conduisent
à être plus proche du consommateur par
des mises en avant de nos productions
locales
ceci dit dans le contexte actuel
sanitaire quelque chose qu'on peut pas
faire donc bon on est réduit à une
mobilisation de ce type là quoi au final
une centaine de tracteurs sont présents
jusqu'en milieu d'après midi sous les
regards surpris des passants
[Musique]